this video contains a ton of restored
bloodborne content
unused dark souls cinematics a
revelation i had about eldon ring
and an incredible secret about the
maiden in black as feat
i'm serious actually and look to the
description for my first official
dark souls merch collaboration this
is the great one beast cut boss
discovered all the way back in 2017
but at the time it had all of its visual
effects missing
luckily foxy hooligans noticed that
these fx ids
matched those of the orphan of cos and
they used those effects to restore this
boss
to its full glory replete with a
lightning dive
giant bolt attack sweeping wave strikes
and a relentless lightning storm i'm
kind of surprised they didn't finish up
this bus
and added to the game but one thing i'm
glad that from software left out
are these unused physical attacks for
the winter lantern
on the other hand here are some attacks
i do wish were in the game
the mykalash marionette was once capable
of throwing its hands
its feet its head and even its
everything at the player there's even a
spin attack
again these were all restored thanks to
foxy hooligans including
more moves for the garden of eyes who
was once able to cast a variety of
spells
it casts these with a small
spider-engraved stone
talisman something that it still holds
in the actual game
lastly the laran cleric enemy was at one
point
supposed to be a boss with a much wider
range of attacks
this fight would have been so well paced
except for
well the frame rate at times and perhaps
had this been an actual boss
it could have been included in
bloodborne's
boss rush dungeons funnily enough these
were close enough to completion
that the official bloodborne strategy
guide actually mentions them
as if they do exist in game though of
course they never made it in
as far as we can tell these boss rushers
would have only featured a small
sequence of bosses probably a themed set
of bosses
located in these unique arenas now it's
impossible to tell
if the boss rushes were meant to be
rooms at the end of a layer
or if they were meant to be their own
separate chalice dungeons i wish this
made it into the game
sakura's game of the year update has
shown that boss rushes
really do suit the souls formula and i
hope they continue to add these to their
games
even if they're just post-launch updates
like with sekiro
also added to sakura in its game of the
year update were remnants
manually recordable phantoms that can be
shared between worlds
they can show hidden rooms they can show
effective techniques
they can even show you glitches that
allow you to skip certain bosses but one
thing i've not seen anyone mention about
these
is that remnants are marked by a small
kunai
a small throwing knife of the exact same
sword used
by lady butterfly who is a boss that's
well versed in
you guessed it summoning phantoms
furthermore
these phantom kunai have the father's
bell charm attached to them
linking them of course to father al
whose forest is also filled with mist
and mystifications
perfect for training in the illusory
arts another thing i'm not sure i've
seen people mention
is this really stunning overlap between
the sunken valley riflemen
and the bandaged lepers featured in
hayao miyazaki's
princess mononoke so both sets of
characters are incredibly talented
marksmen
equipped with long flintlock rifles that
they hold and treasure
at all times both groups exist within a
wooden
gun fort and not only that but both gun
forts defend
a mining town the sunken valley clan are
also bandaged
likely because they live in a valley
full of toxic minerals and the lepers
are bandaged too
because they're suffering from well
leprosy
lastly many of the valued snipers in
iron town are women
and women have a special place in the
sunken valley clan as well
since two of them are the snake eyes
mini bosses who are descended from the
legendary okami
that's so much overlap it's ridiculous
both princess mononake and sakura also
feature the idea of impurity that's
really rooted in japanese culture
both even feature these resilient main
characters with tainted yet powerful
arms sakura's prosthetic arm carries and
is strengthened by
spirit emblems which these
manifestations of regret or bad karma
and ashitaka's arm enlarges when he's in
need of great strength
a side effect of the defilement that he
touched at the beginning of the movie
go and watch that movie if you haven't
it's one of my favorites
moving over to dark souls at one point
there was a cut scene that had a giant
crow
take you away from the painted world
instead of you plunging down from the
plank
obviously very fitting since crows are
such a big part of the painting but it's
unclear
whether the crow would take you out of
the painting or just
to a different part of it speaking of
cut animations
yeah desert sorceresses once had a very
interesting grab attack
but they actually had to cut it because
players kept getting hit on purpose most
of the dragons we fight in the soul
series are more accurately
wyverns as they walk on two hind legs
this is supposed to signify that they're
a more common
modern breed and quadrupedal dragons in
the series are usually ancient dragons
instead
like the gaping dragon sin and medea
however there is one more everlasting
dragon that we haven't been able to get
a good look at
until now zully has discovered this
the ancient guardian dragon you've
probably seen it before
it's actually the enormous dragon that
you spy dead on a mountain in archdragon
peak
once it was likely envisioned as a boss
as well a role that was almost certainly
moved over to
the ancient wyven instead its model
resembles a handful of statues in
archdragon peak
as well as this incredible piece of
concept art which sort of has white hair
swept backwards like the nameless kings
there is
one dog in dark souls 3 that is not like
the others
it's even hidden out of sight in a small
cave to the left of the final bridge
along the path of sacrifice
if you look closely you'll realize it's
maggot infested
and it's incredibly bloated and if you
look even closer
this pup has been on my secret list for
years now but i was reminded of it
because of limit breakers
a channel which has an entire video on
the space-time distortion abilities
of dogs in dark souls 3. i'm sure you've
all noticed that these dogs teleport
while they're chasing you
right well it turns out that it's only
the larger arrow-pierced dogs that do so
and
they only do so off-screen which means
it has something to do with them
entering your render area before they're
ready to do so
so throw the old man a bone and watch
his video if you want specifics
but even more cursed than dark souls 3
dogs is gayle
a slave knight who has successfully
staved off on death longer than any
other character
in game the undead curse and curses in
general
have a visual identity that's associated
with skulls
and i wanted to point out that this
might be why gail's boss design is
literally overflowing with them i like
this because
a part of the dark sigils description is
the darkness of humanity seeps from this
bottomless pitch black hole
the gap filled by the accumulation of
the curse
the curse has been accumulating within
gale for a long time
and it shows in dark souls 3 your
humanity
isn't that valued especially when you
consider yuria's
lord of hollows questline which features
a gameplay mechanic where
embracing your hollowing can actually
make you stronger as it can grant you
free soul
levels on the flip side in the original
dark souls
humanity is definitely a highly valued
resource
when offered up to a bonfire the black
sprites act as a surrogate for the curse
it draws the curse out of your body and
releases the strain that it puts upon
our own humanity thus a hollowing is
reversed
fittingly the original dark souls
apparently used to have
a humanity exchange mechanic as well but
unlike in dark souls 3
where you would give up your humanity to
gain levels
you could actually give up levels to
gain humanity in dark souls 1.
this mechanic was cut but i love how it
reflects that
humanity is more valued in dark souls 1.
i just love how internally consistent
this is
from a law and a gameplay perspective
across
all three souls games speaking of
spanning all three souls games
here's my newest merch project it's
called trilogy with the art designed in
collaboration with zan
valancak put to print by fangamer and
officially licensed with bandai namco
so the signature helmets of the dark
souls cover characters are split into
thirds with a sort of molten estus
linking them together and darker clips
in the backdrop the classic shirt is on
a grey heather and the limited edition
one
is on indigo marked with some choice
graffiti and this one's only available
for two weeks
starting now and then never again so fan
gamer have
some of the best shirt printing in the
industry and
i don't think you'll be disappointed if
you grab one if you do support this
thank you it might actually help me
commission more officially licensed
designs with
bandai namco in the future which would
be really fun
hopefully one day soon namco will show
more of elden ring
their upcoming title and even though
we've talked about the trailer to death
believe it or not there are still some
details i haven't
mentioned so alongside the announcement
trailer this image was shared
to me it really gives off huge dark
souls vibes doesn't it
the coiled sword reminds me of a bonfire
and the character reminds me a lot of
prince lothric
that said though there is one much
darker detail here
the robe this character is wearing might
well be
human skin most obvious is the face
on the cow but even this part of the
robe looks suspiciously like a hand
and if this is skin then this marking
here might have been a tattoo
interesting but i feel like the biggest
revelation i've had relates to something
that you could easily overlook
the logo and the title itself it's easy
to assume that elden ring
might be a physical thing it's been
shattered after all and
there's a guy hammering away at
something in the trailer
of course something this superficial is
unlikely to be the case and
miyazaki has pretty much confirmed this
he claims that
eldon ring is the name given to a
mysterious concept that defines the
world itself
he says it functions as the rules and
rhythm of the world
and that it's been shattered what we're
seeing in the trailer is likely a series
of characters that are coming to terms
with this paradigm
shift now consider the logo four rings
six if you count the two hints of a
circle at the top and the bottom
and four of these rings overlap in the
middle
and that's what i think is the key word
overlap if these rings represent
the rules and rhythm of the world and
they're overlapping
this might be a huge clue about the
rules of the world
because it reminds me of berserk berserk
is a series that from software have been
really liberally inspired by in the past
i'm sure a lot of you know that
and its law features a concept of three
overlapping realms it's a macrocosmic
trinity that consists of the mortal
realm
the astral realm and the ideal many fans
depict these realms as a series of
overlapping rings and what does that
remind you of
so in the mortal realm our bodies exist
it's a physical world where
humanity resides for the most part and i
say for the most part because the mortal
realm does have some fringe connection
to the next world
the astral realm also known as the
afterlife or the netherworld
here ethereal beings reside in yet
another set of overlapping layers the
shallowest layer is called the intestis
which bears similar scenery to the
physical world as they're quite close
and it houses these lower tier astral
beings like
trolls or the regretful dead and
magically inclined humans even have
one foot in this realm and one foot in
the physical realm sometimes
deeper layers contain increasingly
powerful and
supernatural beings that can influence
the world on these
increasingly macrocosmic levels
eventually culminating in
the ideal world a place that holds the
intentionalities
of all life forms it's this swirling
abyss of souls
where the ego itself cannot survive
so there's all of these layers but in
berserk a magnanimous event
called the great roar of the astral
world
eventually occurs which merges the
physical
and the astral world into one global
intestines
chaos ensues the dangers of the astral
realm
are unleashed upon the physical realm
the rules and rhythm
of the world are broken and i bet that
the
shattering of the elden ring is going to
be almost identical to
this event but it's just a theory at the
end of the day it could be nothing
or it could be everything honestly there
could be an entire video here i'm
just kind of waiting for eldon ring to
confirm this on some level
before i consider diving even deeper
into this
theory of overlapping cosmic realms it's
actually really one of the most
interesting parts of berserk for me
another thing i'd like to bring to light
is a discovery by king duran on reddit
who pointed out this really fascinating
detail in the demon souls intro
cinematic
in the still scene that depicts this war
between the first scourge against the
demons
we now notice that these hulking figures
actually bear some sort of resemblance
to
a lot of the cut content enemies the
stomach mouth of this yeti creature can
be seen
here for example the face of this
creature looks like that of the hyena
enemy
and this smaller giant wields a club
like this cut enemy so these enemies
were cut from a level that was
originally supposed to be accessible
via the sixth archstone in the nexus
this archstone was once given to the
great
giants of the northern lands but it's
blackened in game which implies that its
world tendency has become pure black
and it's been completely lost to demons
so
realizing that the enemies that were cut
from the land of the giants
might have been actual giants fighting
in the first scourge that could have
overwhelmed this arch stone
is just so fitting it feels like it
can't be coincidence right
but let's end this video with a truly
incredible observation
no jokes this is serious law so pay
attention
do you know why the maiden in black is
barefoot in the nexus
why her feet are so filthy in the remake
well according to her official profile
on a now removed official website it's
because she's blind
and she uses her feet to feel her way
around the nexus
allowing her to fulfill her duty as a
fire keeper and
keep all the candles lit despite not
being able to see
there's a reason for everything in these
games don't you know thank you for
watching
these videos are a combination of facts
that are largely discovered by
the entire community so in a big way i
am just helping to bring these to a
wider audience
so please make sure you check out the
talented folks in the description
for more facts like this a lot of them
post some amazing stuff
so yeah also consider checking out the
trilogy merch if you're interested and
i'll see you next time